militär und geheimdienste sind sich
sicher putin will wolodimir seelands
kies kopf er will den ukrainischen
präsidenten töten lassen und dass
russland über leichen geht ja das haben
die letzten jahre bereits eindrücklich
bewiesen hier ist putins todesliste
entführt erschossen oder opfer eines
mysteriösen
giftanschlags die spur führt immer
wieder nach russland
wer ihm in die quere kommt lebt
gefährlich journalisten politiker
wirtschaftsleute wladimir putin und sein
russischer geheimdienste einen
erfinderisch wenn es um die beseitigung
unliebsamer personen geht die todesliste
aus moskau ist lang die methoden
vielseitig er wurde gleich zweimal
vergiftet der moskauer journalist und
oppositionelle wladimir karambol sah es
beginnt mit atemnot und endet mit
organversagen
er überlebt wie durch ein wunder
2004 viktor juschtschenko der
oppositionskandidat und spätere
präsident der ukraine wird plötzlich
schwer krank dioxinvergiftung sein
gesicht trägt bis heute die spuren des
anschlags
2006 alexander litwinenko
der russische agent und kreml-kritiker
stirbt an einer vergiftung mit
hochgradig radioaktivem polonium 210
2012 alexander perry pilic nie der
russische geschäftsmann und informant
stirbt beim joggen es wird das gift der
chinesischen pflanze gremium in seinem
wagen gefunden
der ehemalige doppelagent und seine
tochter julia entgehen dem tod nur knapp
sie überleben einen anschlag mit dem
nervengift novikov
2009/10 williams an geely der ehemalige
kommandeur der tschetschenischen milizen
wird im kleinen tiergarten im ortsteil
moabit mutmaßlich im auftrag des
russischen geheimdienstes fsb erschossen
2020 alexej nawalny der erbitterte
gegner wladimir putins wird ebenfalls
mit dem kampfstoff novikov vergiftet in
berlin behandelt und gerettet
die todesliste putin sie scheint jedoch
noch nicht vollständig zu sein rund 400
russische söldner in kiew soll nun
ukraine präsident seelen ski seine
familie und andere wichtige
persönlichkeiten wie die
klitschko-brüder ermorden